right well this question of whether
there's one cycle
or each cycle is part of many is you
know it's not
possible to resolve it there's no way to
know
sort of the way i interpret these things
like
noah and atlantis and the things you
mentioned
is that this one unique
transcendental event that is still ahead
of us
somewhere in the planetary future is the
cause
of all the visionary and mystical
anticipations that you know atlantis
didn't rise and fall
in the past it wrote it will rise and
fall
in the future and all of these things
which we place
in the distant past are actually echoes
from this transcendental object that
and what history is is the unraveling
through the intercession of the dao i
mean you could call it the unraveling or
the witnessing
to the unraveling since i don't think it
depends on us
but the unraveling of the secret
that there is uh you know that history
moves toward a resolution a
transcendence of itself
it can't be like this forever
it hasn't been like this forever this is
something so
new it's like yesterday people stopped
you know beating each other over the
head with
fruits and then this
you know a 15 25 000 year
march toward some kind of self-generated
cultural omega point
where technologies imaging of our own
neural capacity metaphysic
all of this stuff is just turns
incandescent as
we and yet you know people say nothing
is happening
right but it's all totally ordinary that
it's just
hum drum and ho-hum because they can't
see the past you know they can't
they're they have no idea how different
this is exactly
this is different they think this is
every day always has been that's like
i'm always marveling at how we were able
to do things it's like because
i can see a ways back to where i said we
were just
bang each other with sticks or rocks or
or rotten food or whatever now we're
doing this in this kind of space with
these kinds of pieces of even that was
considered stone age
uh five years five years ago right
consider marvel i mean i wish it would
be faster too but all this stuff is
pretty amazing francis
have you had any point in all of this uh
uh become uneasy about the determinism
implied well i've thought about it a lot
my here's what i say about that
[Applause]
an absolute determinism
is one impossible and two
to be avoided at all costs the reason
is if the world were absolutely
determined
then thought doesn't mean anything
i am thinking if the world is absolutely
determined then i am
thinking the thoughts i'm thinking
because i can't think
any others it's just determined
so that puts philosophers out of
business and since i
sort of identify with that why i'm very
concerned to preserve free will how i
think
of what this is doing is
the previous model of time was basically
that what you had to worry about mostly
was
cause and effect the effect of your
activity on the world
keep that clean and move forward
what this idea is saying is
that the topology
of time is not a flat surface
and that you can think of the tao of
your life
as water and it's moving over
over the temporal topology the temporal
landscape
but the temporal landscape is not a flat
plain
it is in fact cut by mountains and
uplifts and
cliff systems so that sometimes your
life runs
quickly and there is high novelty
and sometimes there is uh there are
barriers and the flow
is slowed but the actual
events which constitute
the realization of the potential
of novelty or its absence are freely
determined
so in other words here we have the chart
and it's going along and it's flat
and now there's a huge drop on a certain
day
and now we say what do we know now
all we know is that on this certain day
there's going to be a
shift toward the novel
but we have no idea what
the events will be that will fulfill
this very
generalized kind of prophecy that's the
problem
you keep saying how do we know that this
is really true and not just a
marvelous conversational topic the only
way you can find out if it's true is to
make a specific prediction that could
not have been predicted in the other way
see something coming that nobody else
sees
and then say ah i told you so and then
you know then you know
2012. well i guess that will be 2012.
you have to the shift you see
you can predict shift but if someone
demands that you predict
content then i don't think they
understand how it works
if you could predict content then
the world would have to be seen as
extremely highly determined
so so what you predict is shift
and then if we can get an agreement on
what that means
before the test happens so
you know all theories this is a good
general piece of information that
somebody
passed on to me and i'm forever grateful
if you want to if somebody's pushing an
idea
at you and you want to know just
how reasonable and fair and
so forth they are about this idea
then this is the question you ask
under what circumstances would you agree
that you are wrong you see
now freudians have never answered
this question marxists
are incapable of responding to this
question there are no circumstances
under which marxists and freudians
would feel constrained to abandon
their theories
when you apply that question to this
theory you get
levels of retraction what if nothing
happens
in 2012 at all
well a hard-line
position would be that the wave was
simply calibrated
wrong that only one thing was wrong with
the theory
the end date everything else still holds
some of you may know there's a wonderful
book called
when prophecy fails have you ever read
this book
it's by two stanford sociologists who
um infiltrated a flying saucer cult in
utah
this woman's husband had died and she
had begun getting messages a few months
after his
death and then a few months after that
ouija board messages and a few months
after that he handed her
on to commander gamma who was an
extraterrestrial in orbit around this
planet
who was planning to intervene for the
good of mankind
and she gathered a very small group of
people around her
including these two stanford
sociologists
and the messages became more and more
intense
and finally it became about a meeting
and that it would occur at dawn on a
certain day in a certain place
in the utah desert and these people were
just in a lather
over and you know great excitement they
told
no one they told no one
and prepared and fasted and finally they
drove
to the place where it was to happen and
as dawn
rose over the desert uh
nothing happened and they waited around
until the sun
was beating down and then went back to
headquarters
to regroup well they decided that
they had obviously gotten the message
wrong
and that this was the fallacy
of being secretive that they hadn't had
enough
people helping them figure out what was
going on
so they voted and decided to immediately
call a press conference
and announce the entire thing and their
faith was redoubled and they saw then
that now they were going to
get the aid of interested parties and
publicity
and so forth and so on this is called
the disconformational crisis and
it it happened for christianity as well
because of course christ
said this generation will not pass away
before i will return among you and you
know people
the the first 100 years of christianity
were just totally apocalyptic but
then the hot heads were swept away in
the managerial types and the mbas
got hold of it and said let's squelch
all this end of the world talk and do
some serious investing
so my my position vis-a-vis that is uh
i will be 65 years old a month
before december 22nd 2012 and at that
point i will retire
and i'll be perfectly happy to see this
described you know these histories of
scientific ideas that
have paragraphs that say things like the
later 17th century
saw a flowering of bizarre and eccentric
scientific theories of which so-and-so's
is the most baroque example they can put
me and jose on the same show
[Music]
you